scp-096 versus scp-689  the monster whose face you never want to  see illuminated versus the mass  murdering haunter of the dark who would  win the shy guy or this sinister statue  689 is a small soapstone statue that  puts anyone who sees it in grave danger  once they first see it the second they  look away they'll be instantly killed  and the statue will appear sitting on  their corpse and of course  scp-096 will mercilessly hunt down and  eviscerate anyone who makes the mistake  of seeing its face but despite the  danger of both anomalies we call this  one a draw why the statue can't see and  thus wouldn't activate 096's rage state  also one of the popular theories about  096 is that it's actually blind meaning  it would never see and activate 689  either the two may just awkwardly stand  around until something else happened